it hasn't really hit me yet completely
that it's over the show mostly because
the way our schedule worked for 12 years
this was the natural break that we had
so I'm I'm looking for September to the
fall time when I would normally be
working when we'd start airing and
that's what I think certain things will
start hitting me like oh yeah I mean I
get it logically but there's just got to
be part of me that doesn't get it at all
Jim Parsons opens up about life after
the Big Bang Theory the series finale
aired in May but Jim says the cast is
still closed and texts each other or
lives we're not talking about anything
out of the ordinary yet we're still
texting about stupid day-to-day stuff
and and that's another thing that'll be
interesting as time goes by I don't know
it sounds like anything else in life
when it you kind of can't decide you
can't imagine how it's going to be until
you get there I love you all and I love
you it ended the way I hoped it would
which was that it felt right there were
probably a million different ways that
can feel right I mean I was very I would
talk with some of the writers and I know
that they were as they were writing and
they were nervous about it and I didn't
know what they were writing and they
were like we were nervous about getting
it right and I was like well it's your
show you'll get it right you've created
it you know and they're like well yeah
but it's still it's nerve-racking you
know they will here look at it this way
it's a finale you can't get it
completely right someone's gonna hate it
but I don't think that was actually the
case with this which was really sweet I
didn't feel like anybody didn't like it
to one degree another and that was nice
I thought it wrapped up in the right way
yeah up next Jimmy's reprising his role
in the Broadway play boys in the band
only this time sub Broadway for Netflix
there's so many platforms and so many
ways to do things now maybe things like
that will become more common you know
being able to take full casts and like a
play and put them all in the
movie or whatever but yeah that's really
exciting and that'll be your really
we're gonna start work on that in like
two weeks
and that'll be an interesting need to go
back into that too that'll be a little
trippy I think doing stage work there's
plenty of similarities obviously to any
other time vacuum work but some of the
major difference is like just projection
and the size of a house you're playing
and it suddenly it'll be even quieter
and more intimate than we are right now
and but that's the kind of the part
that's one of the most exciting aspects
of it is the chance to do this that we
this material we know so well we worked
on so long to get to do it in a
different way you get to do it in a more
intimate way and and it will change it I
mean the core story will all be to stay
the same but but it will be a different
beast whether the time we're done with
it it's not a small deal to have that
many out gay actors all the same
production together the actor opened up
to ET at variety and mercedes-benz's
power of pride event in New York City
it's such an honor to be chosen to be
some sort of visible representation of
what pride is because it's sort of an
elusive thing and somebody means
something different to everybody and it
means something I think evolving and
changing to most of us who feel isn't a
pride at different times in our lives
you know and I think the only constant
is that to take pride and who you are
and and not be afraid and not listen
other people who make you feel less than
just go forward of what you're doing and
hopefully you don't have to be too
aggressive to do it but if it comes to
it do it I don't know right now in my
life pride to me is feeling comfortable
in Who I am confident in Who I am
even on days when I don't feel
personally confident to go out into the
world there's that underlying thing of
just like I'm okay being Who I am
going out and doing what I need to do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]